so Gina um to you from Miss Bala what is
scarier beauty pageants or Mexican drug
cartels oh there's no comparison and I
don't want to be a part of either and
they both yeah I'm I I really commend
women that can do beauty pageants I
think that is a very brave and a very
difficult space for sure to be in I'm
what did you have any research for these
roles um did you see any overlapping
skill sets possibly oh I definitely
changed my physicality like my my body I
worked really hard on transforming body
for the character because I definitely
thought she was very different than Jane
and I'm usually living in the chains
face
well yeah that was a huge transformation
for me physically I really loved that
Gloria is just sort of an every woman
who's thrust into these this impossible
situation and let's say to put it nicely
a world it's not so kind of women yes
how do you approach this character
without making her sort of a victim of
these horrible circumstances well I
think that there's a lot of spaces that
women are very aware that we're not
treated well in so as a woman I feel
like I have dealt with those
circumstances many times I've I am
definitely a protector of myself and the
other women around me so when we were
when I got the scripts myself Catherine
Gareth really went in to make sure that
she was a reflection of the women that
we see in everyday life and what was
realistic to each situation in each
scenario and what would she really do in
those circumstances we wanted to portray
a woman that is seldom reflected
on-screen but very much so in you know
in our everyday lives a woman that uses
every aspect of herself to get herself
out of these situations whether that be
like her feminine charms or her
intellect or her wit or whatever it may
be in the circumstance so I really liked
playing that because that's kind of the
way we are in real life
did you um know anything about Laura
Zuniga the woman who the original Miss
Bala was based on I learned about her I
hadn't known prior to the film and I was
able to watch the original after but
that being said it was very much a
reimagining so it's very different than
the original but still giving it
it's that weight that that care and that
paying homage to the first one yeah the
biggest difference I think is you know
Gloria is now a mexican-american instead
of you know a Mexican woman do you think
how does that change sort of some of the
image of the film well you know we never
actually talk about my ethnicity cuz
when we did our background we were
saying that my parents were like maybe
one was Puerto Rican one was Mexican we
never really go back into her background
except for the fact that she lived there
because her father had a monkey I
thought I should he had a factory there
but this identity this dual identity
that Gloria owns this not being Athena
enough in Mexico not being American
enough in America I've walked with my
entire life like I very know much so
know what it is to eat rice and beans in
the house and hamburgers and hot dogs
outside to have a two languages spoken
in the household to feel like another
and yet be born here so I know what that
feeling is and so it's really I think a
lot of Latin X and a lot of first second
third generation Latinos Latinas can
feel a relation to that because I think
we all go through and we still do you
know
you